just let mother nature handle the light
right she can take care of it herself
she gets the sun
up she lets the sun go to bed and it all
happens naturally without having to mess
with our clocks i know it's
wealthy but i think a lot of people are
you know kind of used to you're you're
used to having to change your clocks
whether you're used to the time
difference or not that's
that's up to you but we will have to do
it this weekend if you want to stay on
time
we got a beautiful shot looking out over
the mountains where lee canyon picked up
four inches of snow yesterday
beautiful it's chilly up there 17
degrees at
kyle canyon right now with some west
northwest breezes at times
otherwise we've got lots of 40s around
the valley centennial hills mountains
edge
down into the 30s and again we will be
changing as we change our clocks forward
ahead one hour not only do we lose an
hour of sleep but we're
really just shifting an hour of daylight
from the morning to the evening
it's the whole point 6 52 will be the
sunrise come sunday and 6
47 the sunset so the days do feel
a lot longer when we go go into daylight
saving time we only picked up a tracer
rain yesterday that was it
and really even though we did have some
scattered showers around nothing
measurable
around the valley we are zilcho for the
month and only two tenths of an inch for
the year where we should have
an inch and a half by now so we did get
some scattered showers around even a
little lightning out towards the lake
this low pressure system is still
swirling off the coast
of california it is sinking southward
but you can see how it's twisting and
turning
and spinning moisture back up into
southern nevada
so we still have the opportunity for
more showers today
and there's cold air with it so isolated
thunderstorms
and we'll look for more snow in the
mountains as well so chance of showers
and thunderstorms
later through the morning and afternoon
hours 34 up on the mountain
again four inches yesterday maybe we can
get another inch or two today and
tomorrow
still scattered showers in the forecast
for tomorrow then sunshine
warmer for the weekend wow that looks
great 70 on sunday
clouds and sun to start next week but
70s show up again
later next week